[Music]
so Iran's foreign minister admits this
country has supplied Russia with drones
but he says they were sent before the
invasion of Ukraine Kiev it says Iranian
Kamikaze drones have been used to bomb
cities and energy facilities Tehran says
it wants to see the evidence
our ties with Russia are based on Mutual
interests this hype that some Western
countries staged against Iran saying
that Iran has sent missiles and drones
to be used in the Ukraine war I would
say that it is totally false about
missiles but about drones it is true we
send a number of drones months before
the Ukraine war we agreed with the
Ukrainian foreign minister that if they
have any evidence to prove that Russia
has used any Iranian drone in the war
they can provide us with it
akiv's Mass has about 450 000 homes
without power following attacks the U.S
says it's stepping up aid for Ukraine's
air defenses
we've recognized the acute need for air
defense at this critical moment when
Russia and Russian forces are reigning
missiles and Iranian drones down on the
civilian infrastructure of this country
all the while on the southern front line
Ukraine says it's taken another Village
near curse on Russia has been getting
civilians out of the city we have two
correspondents covering the story I said
beggars in creveury in the Ukraine but
first let's speak to Dr Jabari in Tehran
and also tell us what more we know about
all of this
well the Iranian foreign minister uh
said that the Iranian government sent a
delegation to a European country about
two weeks ago where they were supposed
to meet their Ukrainian counterparts who
were going to present Iranian officials
with uh their documentation or what they
found as evidence that would point to
the fact that the Iranian drones were
indeed being used in this war the
Iranian foreign minister said at the
very last minute the Ukrainian
delegation did not attend this meeting
he believes that this was due to the
pressure exerted on them by the United
States government as well as Germany who
he believes that those governments are
looking for excuses to impose further
sanctions on Iran the issue here is one
the Western powers that are still
remaining signatories so that 2015
nuclear deal that the United States left
in 2018 they're claiming that the sale
of these drones is part is a violation
of that nuclear agreement because under
that agreement and the Iranian
government is not allowed to say to sell
or import any advanced military
equipment or technology now what they
have under the nuclear deal what has
happened since they signed it is in 2020
in October there was a un arms embargo
in place since 2007. that was lifted as
part of the jcpoa as it's known the
Iranian officials have said these
excuses put forth by Western powers are
ludicrous and that the sale of these
drones were part of a contract with the
government of Russia prior to the start
of the war and that it is not in
violation of any agreement or U.N
security Council now what is important
is that the foreign minister today
highlighted the fact that Iran is not
taking sides in this war he said that if
it is proven that these drones are being
used in this conflict that the Iranian
officials will be taking the matter up
with their Russian counterpart
all right also thanks for that uh that's
the picture in Tehran Let's cross it now
to asset bakeries in Creve in Ukraine so
that's a tell us what Ukraine has been
saying about Iran confirming this drone
Supply to Russia
well there's been a statement on
Saturday from the foreign Ministry
spokesman now what he said was that Iran
should realize that their support the
consequences of their supporting
Russia's aggression is much more than
any support they may have from Russia
now the ukrainians have said for months
now that Russia has been using uh
Iranian Iranian drones and uh missiles
now again we've heard from the uh the
Ukrainian air defense that they've shut
down uh drones today although we can't
independently verify that because
restrictions on the media here are quite
considerable but the ukrainians are
saying that they've shut down some
drones but we all do know that Kiev has
said that these drones have been used to
Target Ukraine's infrastructure now the
election straight electricity company
has said that there will be scheduled
black ads in Kiev and seven other
regions as a result of those Russian
strikes on Ukrainian infrastructure and
I said what's the latest on the ground
meanwhile
[Applause]
well in the south of the country in
Carson
what that usually means is that whenever
they take a village these Curson is
generally Flatlands and what that means
is that Russians have to retreat a
considerable distance to get to cover
now croissant itself is really important
to both the Ukrainian and Russian forces
it's the only Regional Capital the
Russians have managed to take since the
start of the war and it is militarily
strategic it's the only place the
Russians forces occupy on the west side
of that danipro River it's a gateway to
Crimea if the ukrainians managed to take
it it would mean that the Left Flank of
the Russians could be vulnerable to
attack but the pro-russian authorities
in corsano said that they've seen a real
escalation of shelling of person by the
ukrainians but they say the front lines
remain the same and the Russian Ministry
of Defense has said that they've
repelled Ukrainian attacks in her son
from the from the north now this
offensive we don't exactly know what's
going on because we're not allowed into
that area the Ukraine is a very
tight-lipped about what's going on what
they're doing but this could take months
it the ukrainians have been saying that
rather than evacuating they are
evacuating civilians it looks like the
Russians are reinforcing their positions
in person City because they won't want
to give that up without a fight because
of his strategic importance to the
Russians all right that's it thanks for
that acid thank you